now I dive into your virgins internet  for personal use is so wrong but feels  so good kaylynn your performances below  subpar please see Anna for Korean life  advice son Slim Shady is I'm the real  shady all you other slim Shady's are  just imitating so won't the real Slim  Shady please stand up please stand up  please stand up  no one notices your biceps Kailen Kailen  please don't pop your collar I have  important news the results of the  internal audit are in and it turns out  that I'm the real Slim Shady and all the  other slim Shady's are just imitating so  what does that make you Kahlan don't you  love coming in early don't have to deal  with anyone's nonsense yeah I'm same  show you something real shady all you  other slim Shady's are just imitating  mm-hmm  you hear that song hmm you heard that  song yeah  Eminem's it's good kind of older though  check on some Trudy just one brew Shady  I'll play for you later  you